now having reached the very highest
levels of the premier league and indeed
international football patrice evra now
has a very different story to tell the
former manchester united and france
captain has revealed in a new book that
he was sexually abused as a teenager
patrice joining us now hello thanks for
joining us on the programme this morning
talk to us about your new book
uh my new book is uh it's all about my
life it's a philosophy of life showing
to the
young generation you know sometimes they
just see like the end of the process so
it's a long journey many things happen
to myself
really important things like we said the
racially abused fighting against the
races and you know growing in the street
so many things was a disadvantage but i
never give up resilience was my worst so
that's a book where i want the young
generation to to don't find any excuse
you know and if they want to succeed in
life
and you were physically abused as well
yeah i said at the age of 13 something
uh
it was difficult for me to to speak
about i only revealed that to my mom
now i'm 40 years old so it was something
really difficult and it happened uh
when i was 13 and like i said i was
shamed about it
i was feeling like a coward because
i'm speaking out today because i want to
help other kids you know around the
world i'm not doing it for myself
because i've been surviving with that
for so many years so that's why i'm
encouraging any kids to have the same
abuse as myself to come out and to speak
to someone they can trust and they're
gonna feel even much better and the
world will support them and helping them
and the person that abuse you did they
um subsequently as a result of what they
did to you have they faced the full
weight of the law
uh yes in uh i think uh when i was 24
years old the police called me and was
still playing for monaco and uh
they they asked me actually if that
person abused me because they had some
complaint about the child and i like i
say no because
absolutely because i was famous and
still ashamed of myself so
i just erased that people from my memory
that person from my memory i don't know
he look i don't know his name i don't
know if he's in jail i don't know if
he's dead so
because i just deny everything
yeah but it's really important isn't it
for somebody like you to talk about when
something like that happens because it
gives other youngsters you're only 13 at
the time um the strength potentially to
come forward
and tell an adult
no but exactly i think it's not you know
being weak if you don't talk about it
it's just you know it's a trauma and
sometimes mentally you're not ready to
talk about it but that's why i want to
go out and i received a lot of uh of
message people were saying this has
happened to me patrice thank you for for
coming out because they need to have
like yeah you need to be brave but it's
about it's more about about trusting
trusting someone won't judge you about
what you're going to say so that's why
i'm really encourage them and
it already worked because so many people
already say they're going to talk
they're going to say things because we
need to stop that and it's not being
weak and don't be ashamed don't think
you you you know you're not a good
person because i think that so many
people for so many years she's such a
good human being but i never feel that
way because of that uh sexual abuse
because i was feeling first shame of
myself i was feeling as a coward so
it's really easy when you say like you
have to talk you have to talk but you
need to be ready mentally to do that and
me
thanks to my
uh
the woman of my life margo
she opened myself emotionally and i had
enough of that toxic masculinity and
that's why i was able also to to open
myself
yeah and of course
we know very well of the racist abuse
that you faced as well from um
luis suarez um from liverpool
yeah like like i said i would never call
louise rice as a racist person because i
don't know him close enough but that day
of course he used some some racist words
but the racism is it's all about
education you know i said no no anyone
in this world born as a racist person
and now i had enough like all those big
industries pretending they want to do
something against the races because
nothing is changing and
you know when we talk about that
superior league they they shut down a
project he didn't even start so don't
tell me the football instinct they can
do nothing against the races even the
platform the social media uh when uh
we had something about the kobe 19
straight away you've been flying but
when it's about race is coming and i
have got racist comments i'm not trying
to any social media because you can
block them you can delay them but i
think we can do much better
in fact
yorkshire cricket has come forward
just within the last few days talking
about the racist abuse that he had
institutional racism as far as he was
concerned
within yorkshire cricket club and he
said that it just went on it was
considered as banter and nobody seemed
to want to do anything
about it i'm guessing that was a similar
situation in football up until very
recently where
racist abuse was was considered banter
was it in the in the changing rooms
but but of course it's considering
banter and to be honest is
is normal but that's why i say stay in
silence now is a crime but the truth is
like
when you don't touch people's pockets
people won't do anything that's why i'm
talking about the primarily like because
people feel like the fifa the wafer is
going to touch their pocket but
what about the races because it's just
like yeah can people losing life it's
funny but it's not funny when i used to
i was 70 years old i play in italy
people were throwing banana on my face
and i don't think it's funny but i never
gear up i never find any excuses that's
why i want people to the same color as
mine
to work even like more harder but when
you start losing your life because of
your color that's when you know we have
to stop
okay patrice evra written his
autobiography i love this game it's good
to talk to you thank you for joining us